Hallo, schönen guten Abend. Ich heiße Dr. Günis. Ich bin zuständiger Arzt für Sie. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen dieses anonyse Gespräch führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir. Ich habe solche Schmerzen, ja.
Welche Schmerzen haben Sie denn?
Ja, wissen Sie, mein rechter Fuß tut unglaublich weh. Und das ist wie aus heiteren Himmel gekommen. Ich weiß gar nicht.
Also das sind ganz, ganz starke Schmerzen vorne am Fuß. Ich kann überhaupt nicht auftreten.
Okay, ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen. Es ist sehr unangenehm für Sie, aber zuerst möchte ich Ihre persönliche Daten nachfragen.
Ja, natürlich müssen wir wissen, wer ich bin. Klar.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Frank Betke.
Frank, könnten Sie Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, B-E-T-H-G-I, Betke.
Herr Betke, wie alt sind Sie denn?
Ich bin 46.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8.03.46.
66, oder?
46.
Ach, ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
Sorry, natürlich, 78.
78, okay.
Ja, das ist normal, das ist kein Problem.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Müssen Sie sich jetzt vorstellen. Ja, so 114, 115 kg wiegen ich.
115 ungefähr, oder?
Ja, ungefähr.
Okay.
Herr Betke, haben Sie schon gesagt, Ihre rechte Beine haben Sie ganz stark geschmissen.
Nicht im Bein, im Fuß.
Ja, rechte Fuß. Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie denn?
Ja, das sching gestern Abend und eigentlich in der Nacht schingen das an.
Ich bin aufgewacht und bin aufgeschrekt.
Ja, wieso tut man Fuß so weh?
Und dann habe ich mir das angeguckt.
Ich wollte eigentlich auch die Toilette gehen, dann habe ich gemerkt,
ich kann gar nicht auftreten mit dem Fuß.
Okay, oh je.
Und dann habe ich auch gesehen,
dass das ganz dick und geschwollen ist und ganz rot der Fuß vorne.
Ganz der Fuß, meine See.
Nein, eigentlich mehr so vorne, der große C und drunter rum.
Okay.
Haben Sie erst einmal gehabt oder?
Das habe ich noch nie erlebt, sowas.
Und ich habe dann überlegt, ob ich irgendwo,
irgendwo gegengestoßen bin oder ob mir da was draufgefallen ist bei der Arbeit.
Aber ich trage bei der Arbeit eigentlich Sicherheitsschuhe.
Also ich kann mir das gar nicht erklären.
Ja, und dann Sie sich gar keine gestürzt oder aufgefallen oder gestoßen.
Ich bin nicht gefallen oder ist es nix draufgefallen, ich habe mich nicht gestoßen.
Okay, okay, verstehe ich ja.
Und können Sie bis zu Ende aushalten diese?
Ja, jetzt bin ich ja auch schon ein paar Stunden unterwegs
und wenn ich nicht da draufstehe und nicht rumlaufen muss, geht es eigentlich ja.
Haben Sie dagegen Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, also ich habe versucht und habe Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Na 600, die habe ich so, wenn man irgendwie, wenn man mal Kopfschmerzen hat
oder wenn mal irgendwas ist, dann nehme ich das wohl.
Also hat ein bisschen geholfen oder?
Nicht wirklich.
Okay, okay.
Herr Birke, wie stark ihr Schmerzen auch der eine Schmerz,
oder von ein bis zehn, eins sehr leichter und zehn sehr starker Schmerzen erspricht?
Oh, also das sind schon wirklich üble Schmerzen.
Also ich würde sagen so zwischen sieben und acht so in dem Bereich.
Also das Sticht und Klopf in dem Fuß, der ist heiß und das es unglaublich schmerzt hat.
Unglaublich.
Ist der stechend oder sichend oder hochhend?
Ja, stechend, ist schon stechend und ja und das klopft richtig in den Fuß.
Ja, klopft eine Schmerz.
Herr Birke, haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie Sie fieberig?
Fieber, nein, nein, nein, das ist nur im Fuß, das es weh tut.
Sonst fühle ich mich eigentlich ganz normal, wie immer.
In der Nacht haben Sie ein Schütterlfrost oder nach Schweiß bemerkt?
Nein, nein, das war nichts. Ich bin nur aufgewacht wegen der Schmerzen.
Okay, in der letzten Zeit haben Sie ab oder zu genommen?
Ja, schön wär's, wenn ich mal abgenommen hätte. Nein, nein, hier habe ich aber nicht.
Ah, okay.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen wegen der Schmerzen?
Ja, wegen der Schmerzen bin ich jetzt wie gesagt normalerweise schlag ich wie ein Bär.
Ich schleich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen, aber meine Frau beschwert sich,
dass ich immer schnarche, aber ansonsten kann ich wohl schlagen.
Okay, richtig. Also, Herr Birke, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Oh, der ist gut. Ja, von nichts kommt nichts.
Okay. Was essen Sie gerne besonders?
Ja, zum Essen gehört bei mir schon ordentlich Fleisch dazu.
Ja, also ich esse morgen schon gerne ein Wurstbrot oder so und mittags muss auch Fleisch auf den Teller.
Ja, und ja, so, mir schmeckt es schon sehr, sehr gut und meine Frau kocht sehr, sehr gut.
Oh, oh, wie schön. Okay. Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Jetzt, akut nicht, nein, nein, nein. Und normalerweise, ich habe ja, kann alles essen, ja.
Und manchmal habe ich so ein bisschen so saures Aufstoßen, dann trinke ich mal Schnaps und dann muss das auch wieder funktionieren, ja.
Herr Birke, haben Sie noch, noch, sonst noch etwas beschwerden außer diesem starker Fußchie-Massen?
Nein, sonst fühle ich mich eigentlich ganz gut, deswegen bin ich ja so, ja, so verwundert, was damit los ist.
Ja, okay. Und letzte Frage für die Bechwerden, haben Sie eine Farbeveränderung an dieser Stelle bemerkt?
Sie meinen an meinem Fuß von Ja, das dick und rot.
Ja, okay. Also da fühlt es sich auch heiß an, also ich habe kein Fieber oder so, aber da am Fuß fühlt es sich heiß an.
Ah, heiß an, okay. Ich habe dann auch geguckt, ob ich da irgendwo ein Splitter habe oder so, aber beziehungsweise ich habe gucken lassen, ich kann da ja nicht hingucken selber, ne?
Das ist der Bauchemweg.
Würden Sie sich an der Fuß einen Taub heiß gefühlt?
Taub ist er nicht, nein, nein, schön wärs, wenn der Taub wäre, dann würde er nicht so weh tun, ja.
Ah, okay. Also Herr Birke, leiden Sie unter chronische Erkrankungen, so wie Alteszucker, Bruthochdruck oder Schichtdröse und Befunktion?
Alteszucker habe ich ja wohl hoffentlich noch nicht, ich bin da erst 46, aber ja, also mein Hausarzt hat mal gesagt, meine Fettwerte sind zu hoch, ja.
Aber ich habe da neben da keinen Medikament dagegen.
Ah, okay, nehmen Sie keine Medikamente dagegen?
Nein, nein.
Außer Brutgrockwerte und leiden Sie unter weitere chronische Erkrankungen?
Also wie gesagt, manchmal habe ich Sudbrennen, da habe ich dann Umebrazul, das kann ich dann einnehmen nach Bedarf, ne?
Okay. Wie viel Medikament nehmen Sie ein?
Ach, weiß ich nicht, was da drauf steht auf der Packung.
Ich habe da so eine Packung in meinem Pferdchen da liegen und kann Ihnen aber jetzt nicht sagen, wie viel da drin ist.
Ich mache Sie keine Sorgen. Ich werde Ihrem Hausarzt fragen.
Wie heißt Ihre Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Müllas.
Dr. Müllas?
Mhm.
Okay. Nehmen Sie, regeln Sie sich oder bei Bedarf andere Medikamenten?
Nein, also wie gesagt, diese Tabletten gegen Sudbrennen und dann bei Schmerzen habe ich eben Päckchen mit Ibuprofen rumliegen
und wenn ich dann Schmerzen habe, kann ich dann mal das vonnehmen.
Okay. Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, Herr Bettke?
Ja, da war ich noch jung, da war ich auch noch nicht ganz so rund wie jetzt.
Da habe ich den Winter rausbekommen. Das ist 20 Jahre her.
Ah, 20 Jahre her.
Sie waren ungefähr 26.
Ja, ja.
Okay. Und gibt es sonst noch etwas als Voroperationen?
Nee, sonst bin ich noch nicht operiert worden.
Okay. Okay, richtig. Rauchen Sie, Herr Bettke?
Nee, also rauchen tu ich nicht.
Noch nicht, meine Sie, oder?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Oh, wie schön. Drücken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, das schon eher. Also so zwei, drei Bier trinke ich schon jeden Tag.
Zwei, drei, vielleicht regelnmäßig, oder?
Ja, ganz regelnmäßig eigentlich, ja.
Und wie gesagt, ja, wenn es mal etwas zu feiern gibt oder wie gesagt, wenn der Magen mal so ein bisschen ärger macht,
dann trinke ich auch nochmal einen Schnaps dazu, aber überwiegend trinke ich Bier.
Okay, gelegentlich trinken Sie Schnaps, oder?
Ja, hin und wieder mal, ja.
Okay, nehmen Sie die folgende Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dritten?
Nee, also damit habe ich noch nichts zu tun gehabt.
Wunderbar.
Herr Bettka, leiden Ihre Erden chronische Erkrankungen so wie Bulltockdruck,
sogar Krankheit, oder?
Meine Mutter ist gesund und mein Vater, der ist schon eine Weile tut.
Der hatte Magenkrebs, ja.
Magenkrebs.
Wie ist der, jetzt, so Stand, jetzt ist er gesund, oder?
Nein, nein, mein Vater ist verstorben.
Verstorben, okay, ja.
Okay.
Herr Bettka, ich bitte Sie ein bisschen geduld.
Ich muss nicht nur diese Anamnesik-Esprich führen, sondern auch dokumentieren.
Das ist sehr, sehr wichtig für Ihre Gedeugnisse zu stellen.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Sie sind einzeln kennt.
Ich bin einzeln kennt, ja.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Schlosser und arbeite in einem Metallverabendungsfirma.
Ein Metallverabendungsfirma. Was machen Sie genau?
Ja, so Maschinenbaugeschichten.
Maschinenbau, okay.
Haben Sie Alltagstress oder beide in der Arbeit?
Ja, manchmal geht es schon ein bisschen schnell zu.
Aber eigentlich ist das Stress eigentlich nicht.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Leben Sie Ihre Familie zusammen?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Und natürlich leben wir alle unter einem Dach.
Okay, hoffentlich sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Die sind alle gesund, ja.
Schön.
Das freut mich sehr.
Leben Sie Ihre Genmüse Sport, Herr Werthier?
Sieht nicht so aus.
Zum Sport komme ich nun wirklich nicht.
Früher, als ich jung war, habe ich mal ein bisschen etwas gemacht.
Da habe ich mal geboxt und war auch immer schwimmen.
Aber jetzt mache ich schon ewig lang keinen Sport mehr.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Ist Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein, ich kann alles vertragen.
Ich habe keine Allergie, nein, nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie in der letzten Seite Ausland gewesen?
An letzter Frage, sind Sie vorständig geimpft, Herr Werthier?
Meinen Weg zu Corona?
Kinderkrankheiten auch.
Unser kranker Kind, das ist schon ewig her.
Ja, und ja, so wegen der Arbeit müssen wir immer,
also falls man sich da mal verletzt,
müssen wir immer eine täterlos Impfung haben.
Aber und Corona bin ich auch geimpft, ja.
Okay.
Gut.
Wir sind fast fertig, Herr Bettka.
Möchten Sie sonst noch etwas ergänzen,
von denen ich wissen musste?
Ich habe Ihnen jetzt schon viele Fragen beantwortet.
Eigentlich bin ich ja nur wegen meinem Fuß hergekommen.
Weil der Fuß so weh tut.
Und jetzt möchte ich natürlich wissen,
dass man dagegen machen kann.
Ja, das ist ja so plötzlich gekommen.
Ja, ich kann noch nicht sagen, was Sie haben, Herr Bettka.
Es ist ein bisschen höch.
Aber wir müssen zuerst ein paar Massnahmen durchführen.
Sobald die Allergebnisse erhalten haben,
werde ich Sie schrittfürschlich informieren.
Was Sie genau haben.
Wir sind, das klingt gut, ja.
Wir arbeiten als großes und erfahrenes Team.
Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorge.
Ich will natürlich schon morgen wieder zur Arbeit gehen.
Insofern, die warten ja auf mich.
Ja, hochwahrscheinlich empfehle ich Ihnen heute bei uns bleiben.
Da muss ich noch zu Hause anrufen, dass ich hier bleibe.
Aber das können wir ja nachher machen.
Ja, bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Untersuchungssaal.
Ich komme gleich.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Herr Bettke, haben Sie in den letzten Tagen
an einem Party oder Grillparty teilgenommen?
Oder besonders viel Alkohol getrunken?
Nein, nicht so viel wie sonst auch immer.
Nein, war keine Grillparty.
Die zweite Frage ist,
haben Sie eine Farbeveränderung in Ihrem Urin bemerkt?
Da habe ich nicht so genau hingeguckt.
Aber wäre mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen,
ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, das war das.
Ich würde gerne wissen, warum die erste Frage,
hast du gestattet?
Kannst du bitte erklären?
Ja, weil ich habe gedacht,
vielleicht hat der Patient vor der Beschwerden besonders viel Alkohol getrunken
und besonders viel Fleisch gegessen.
Das hat so eine Krankheit geführt.
Das ist meine Verducht.
Ich will noch nichts voraus sagen.
Aber er ist immer viel Fleisch.
Er hat nicht besonders viel Fleisch gegessen oder vorgestanden.
Er ist immer viel Fleisch.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Ist Ihnen eine Vergrößerung der Lymphnoten aufgefallen?
Lymphnoten.
Wo müsste ich denn da gucken?
Müßt ich jetzt nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Jetzt heute Nacht musste ich mal auf die Toilette,
aber normalerweise eigentlich nicht.
Ich glaube, ich bin nur aufgewacht
und musste dann deswegen auch die Toilette.
Aber normalerweise habe ich keine Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen.
Zwei Fragen.
Okay, okay, danke schön.
Eine Frage?
Bitte.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden an den anderen Gelenken?
Nee, das ist nur der eine Fuß.
Nur der eine Fuß, der ist mir einmal richtig ganz deutsch schmerzhaft.
Deswegen habe ich aber erlegt, ob ich mir da irgendwas reingetreten habe
oder ob mir etwas draufgefallen ist, aber da war nix.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich erinnere mich nicht, Strahlen des Schmerzes sind irgendwo hinaus.
Nein, die sind nur da vorne am großen Zähn und also da im vorderen Fußbereich.
Aber strahlen nicht aus.
Danke schön.
Er wurde aber tatsächlich noch nicht gefragt, haben Sie recht?
Ja.
Ich würde gerne, ja, es ist wichtig folgende Fragen, ich denke,
haben Sie so etwas wie einen Insekten-Tisch, in 60, an Ihrem Finger bemerkt?
Finger, am großen Zähn man.
Am großen Zähn, weil Sie haben gesagt, keine Trauma.
Eine Kollegin hat gesagt, hat gefragt, gestern viele Alkohol getrunken
und eine Piknik zum Beispiel machen und eine Insekten-Tisch.
Okay, aber ich habe ja gesagt, dass meine Frau geguckt hat,
ob da irgendeine Verletzung am Fuß ist und da war nichts.
Und da könnte man jetzt sagen, der Insekten-Tisch wäre so summiert.
Also nein, ich habe auch keinen Stich am Fuß.
Und mich hat auch nix gestochen.
Ich hatte auch ja immer Socken und Schuhe an, wenn ich draußen bin.
Zwei verheerende Fragen, ich denke, eins dauert und zwei mit der Zeit.
Verschlägt hat oder verbessert?
Ja, die sind schlimmer geworden mit der Zeit und sind in der letzten Nacht aufgetreten.
Aufgetreten, mit der Zeit, dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Gehen nicht weg, nein.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestern, Frau Gerhard.
Wie als erstes geschickt war, anfangen.
Dann müssen wir Dr. Günis fragen, ob er zum Arzt-Arzt-Beschrieb bereit ist?
Ja, ich bin bereit.
Er ist gut.
Schönen guten Abend Frau Ober-Estin.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Darf ich kurz vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich. Er haben die gesehen.
Wer haben die denn gesehen?
Ja, es geht um Frank Betke, ein 46-Jährige-Patient.
Er stellte sich bei uns in der Notaufnahme stechende große Sehschmerzen rechts vor.
Er berichtete gleichzeitig über ein Thema und Ödem.
Die Schmerzen liegt auf der Schmerzskala bei 7 bis 8.
Die vegetative Anamnese wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese wurde verneint, das müssen Sie mir erklären.
Er hat 5 Verden abhängig ins Omni, aber normalerweise hat er nicht.
Als Vorerkrankungen klagte er über hypertrygulsaridämie.
Aber er...
Er war wirklich iber?
Hypertrygulsaridämie.
Also ja, hm?
Und Pyrrhosis.
Äh, dagegen nimmt er regelmäßig Omeparasol einmal täglich.
Aber die Dosierung ist unbekannt.
Das nimmt er regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Äh, das habe ich nicht ganz genau gefragt.
In der beider Untersuchung werde ich nachfragen.
Äh, als Anfang Operationen hatte er mit 26 Appendectomie.
Äh, er ist nicht rauchel, er trinke, regelmäßig 2 bis 3 Flasche Bier,
gelegentlich Schnaps.
Äh, Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese, äh, sein Vater ist an Magenkarzinum gestorben,
seine Mutter ist gesund.
Er ist einselkind, verheiratet, habe 3 Kinder,
arbeitet als Maschinenbautechniker in Metarenfilmen.
Er ist vollständig geäumt, ist ihm keine Allergie bekannt.
Und, ja, das war es.
Okay, was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung?
Ja, im, im großen und ganzen, äh, gehe ich von ersten, äh,
Hyper-Ürsemi, äh, Hyper-Ürsemi-Gichtamfall, also Podagra.
Mhm, genau.
Das könnte es alternativ noch sein.
Äh, differenziell diagnostisch, äh, kommen auch eine,
eine Artritis, äh, eine Kollegionose oder Vaskuliten,
äh, könnte auch sein.
Äh, ich, ja, denke ich...
Was könnte unter uns dann noch sein?
Äh, äh, er klackte keine, äh, äh,
Verletzung oder so.
Aber auch könnte, äh, wir müssen äh,
natürlich eine, äh, äh, Boroleose, Boroleose auszuschließen, ja.
Einmal das auszuschließen?
Äh, Boroleose.
Boroleose, ah, ja, genau, das ist ja auch noch eine Möglichkeit, ja.
Okay.
Äh, natürlich, es könnte auch, äh, ein spontan Fraktur sein, ja.
Genau.
Mhm, gut.
Ja, was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Äh, zuerst äh, äh, achte ich besonders in der Inspektion, äh,
der Ährthema und Ährthema, äh,
bei der Palpation achte ich, äh, natürlich,
Durchblutung, äh, äh,
perferi...perferi, äh,
perferi Durchblutung.
Perferedurchblutung, äh, und...
Und gucken Sie nur den rechten Fuß an?
Äh, ja, gleichzeitig, äh,
die anderen Fuß. Genau, also seitens Vergleich ist wichtig, ne? Ja, hoffen wir, dass er beide
Füße gewaschen hat. Ja, bei der Palfasion achte ich natürlich ein... Gesundheit. ...heiß,
eine Überwärmung und natürlich ein Druckbare-Ödem oder nicht. Ein Druckbare-Ödem, okay. Gut, was machen
Sie noch mit den Patienten? Labor Diagnostik meiner Siehe, oder? Ja, zum Beispiel, was würden Sie denn
Labor Diagnostik untersuchen? Als Labor Diagnostik prüfe ich, so als ein Blutbild, ein Hyper-Ürychemie,
Leber- und Nierenwerte, Reaktiv. Was mit Entzündungswerten? Ja, natürlich, dann müssen wir die BSE, CRP
und Lykos-1000 prüfen. Und das würde sich doch anbieten unter Umständen, wenn da jetzt nicht so schnell
Ergebnisse vorliegen. Was würde man vielleicht noch machen? Die Erkenntnisse außer Hyper-Ürychemie.
Ja, vielleicht beide, so eine Untersuchung können wir ein Ergos feststellen an der...
Das wäre möglich, ja. Und was könnte man noch feststellen mit Bildgebung? Ein Bus-Rentgen in zwei Ebenen können wir
eine Fraktur spontan auszusetzen. Ja, sehr gut. Gut, ja, dann hinsichtlich Ihres Borbäliose-Verdachtes,
was würden Sie da Labor diagnostisch machen? Ja, beide diagnostisch, Serologie müssen wir überprüfen.
Genau. Ja, sehr gut. Gut, ja, sollte sich Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, dass der also eine Hyper-Ürychemie hat,
was wäre dann die Therapie? Ja, ich würde gerne empfehlen, die zuerst Gewichtabdame, weil er adipös ist.
Und ein wichtiger, zuerst möchte ich ein Diät und Gewichtabdame... Aber das nutzt
ihm mal jetzt akut nix. Er muss ja irgendwas zur Erkunftbehandlung erst mal kriegen, der arme Mann.
Ja, natürlich. Erst mal möchte ich ein Bildbuch, ein stationale Aufnahme, Schmerztherapie, Analgesie.
Ja, das würde man da geben. Und... Was würden Sie geben zur Schmerztherapie?
Als Schmerztherapie, ja, in der Erkunft.
So erst und eine Hyper-Ürychemie, alle Prünen.
Sehr gut. Das wollte ich hören. Gut. Und ja, es kam gerade noch eine Empfehlung.
Wir haben gesagt Gewichtabnahme und entsprechende Diät. Aber was ist gezielt? Welche Diät ist besonders erforderlich?
Ja, Fett und Fleischarme, besonders wichtig für ihn.
Ja, ja. Also Purinarme-Kost, das ist natürlich für jemanden, der Essen als Hobby hat, eine echte Herausforderung.
Dass er sein Lebensstil ändern muss. Das ist immer das große Problem.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was mit Herrn Betge ist.
Und insbesondere bin ich auf die Laborwerte gespannt.
Ja, okay. Gut, dann haben wir es geschafft.
Ja, können wir auch empfehlen, Alkohol gerade in Cyan, natürlich.
Oh ja, das wäre vielleicht noch eine gute Idee.
Ja, Purinarme-Diet, Alkoholabstinenz und dann natürlich Alloporinol.
Ja, dann, ja, was kann ich Ihnen sagen?
Anamnese war schön. Sie sind schön auf den Patienten eingegangen.
Sie haben auch gemerkt, dass er irgendwann so ein bisschen ungeduldig wurde und nicht verstanden hat,
warum Sie jetzt so viele Fragen noch stellen.
Er ist doch nur wegen seines Fußes da.
Und, was soll der ganze Quatsch?
Haben Sie aber schön gemacht, haben gesagt, ja wissen Sie, ich muss das fragen, und das gehört dazu.
Und wir müssen ein gutes Bild vom Gesamtgeschichte, von der Gesamtgeschichte bekommen.
Und gleich haben Sie es geschafft, haben Sie sehr schön gemacht.
Ja, und hinterher im Arztbericht habe ich eigentlich ganz am Anfang etwas vermisst,
dass Sie sagen, Herr Betke ist ein 46-jähriger Patient, deutlich übergewichtig,
wer sich mit folgenden Beschwerden bei uns vorstellen.
Und da haben Sie auch geschafft, irgendwie die Formulierung so hinzubekommen, das, was gefehlt hat.
Also, er stellte sich starke Schmerzen im rechten Vorderfuß vor, haben Sie gesagt.
Aber da muss man irgendwo sagen, er stellte sich wegen,
starke Schmerzen im Vorfußbereich des rechten Fußes vor.
Dieser Satz, das ist der erste Satz, den Sie eigentlich von sich geben.
Damit steht und fällt der erste Eindruck bei den Prüfern.
Machen Sie sich da eine gute Formulierung, fertig, dass Sie da einen grammatikalisch
richtigen, vollständigen und nicht ultralang Satz sagen.
Alle Zusatzinformationen können Sie hinterher noch bringen,
aber Sie müssen selber noch wissen, wie Ihr Satz angefangen hat, welche Teile dazugehören.
Also, er stellte sich wegen starker Schmerzen im rechten Vorfuß vor,
die heute Nacht plötzlich aufgetreten sind.
Was weiß ich danach, können Sie das ganze Spektrum, was Sie abgefragt haben, berichten.
Er beschreibt die Schmerzqualität als stechend.
Die Schmerzen sind zunehmend.
Er beschreibt sie mit einer Intensität von 7 bis 8 auf der Skala.
Das können Sie alles nachbringen, aber der erste Satz muss richtig stehen.
Was mir so ein bisschen aufgefallen ist, dass die Verbindung bei der Nachfrage war,
beim Patientengespräch, haben Sie schöne Übergänge gemacht, beim Arztgespräch,
war das ein bisschen abrupt.
Wo ich nicht einverstanden bin, Sie haben gesagt, ich weiß nicht mehr genau,
Sie haben eben nicht gesagt, die vegetative Anamnese, ich weiß nicht mehr,
was Sie gesagt haben, gibt es nicht oder so ähnlich.
Sie haben nicht gesagt, die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf.
Mir ist aufgefallen, deswegen habe ich auch gleich reklamiert.
Das war eine komische Formulierung, müssten Sie vielleicht noch mal nachhören.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, was Sie gesagt haben.
Aber ich habe gleich gemerkt.
Oder ja, vegetative Anamnese wurde verneint.
Der Patient kann keine Anamnese verneinen.
Also vegetative Beschwerden wurden verneint, das könnte man sagen.
Aber normalerweise ist eben die Formulierung, die vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Wobei er ja gesagt hat, er hat heute Nacht schlecht geschlafen,
das haben Sie auch gesagt.
Aber er hat auch gesagt, dass er schnarcht, was natürlich zu seinem Habitos passt.
Dass er ein übergewichtiger Patient ist.
Sie haben nach seinem Appetit gefragt.
Da hätte man vielleicht bei dieser Gelegenheit noch sagen können,
dass die Frage nach seinem Appetit, dass er die sehr positiv beantwortet hat.
Und dass er eben auch bestätigt hat, dass er eine sehr fleischlastige Ernährung hat.
Das ist alles ja so ein Ziel für die entsprechende Richtung.
Gut, ja, das war es.
Das Omeprazul hat ja gesagt, nimmt er nicht ständig ein, sondern nur bei Bedarf.
So, der Nacht war es.
Aber dann eigentlich Dialog war verständlich, also Arztgespräch.
Als ich gefragt habe, welches die nächsten Maßnahmen sind,
da kam ja alles und insofern würde ich sagen, dass das dann so in Ordnung war.
Aber wie gesagt, diese eine zentrale Erste Satz, lassen Sie sich da was Gutes einfallen.
Machen Sie eine Standardformulierung, die Sie dann nach Bedarf variieren können,
aber wo Sie sich absolut sicher sind, dass Sie da einen präzisen, richtigen Satz an den Anfang stellen.
Das ist der erste Eindruck. Das ist wichtig.
Gut.
Dankeschön.
Ich sag mal, so viel für heute?
Ja.